[Music]
uh
at
gnome underscore phi on twitter sent me
this one it's a movie trailer enjoy
does it sound like frozen is selling his
influence to fans
i feel a little bit like kind of shitty
thing is going on he's selling his
influence to fans
all right uh this one is called sharp
stick i guess it's a trailer
two
people
having
sex together what the [ __ ] is this
that's a child right am i wrong why are
we doing this uh two
people
having
sex together
what the [ __ ]
mama always says love can neither be
created nor destroyed
but uh mom but what about dad
what about that
she's never heard her father's voice
um let me see who is this hoe um
oh she's like no she just looks young
she's 27.
i thought it was okay they're probably
having her pay they're probably having a
[ __ ] kid play when she was a kid yeah
i think you might be right i've had my
heart broken
someone who is destined to find love so
when it appears oh hold on my tart
senses went off
is the kid next to her
it looked like a little bit look at that
look at the camera
quality
yeah one who is destined to find love so
when it appears in my past
it's the punisher
i have to take it do you even get
crushes not really i feel like i was
born with a crutch i was like in the
nursery crushing on a fetus
what is that what humor is now for
zoomers well bob women wrote this for
sure
okay let's see the imdb i'm not gonna
just women wrote this for sure
did a woman writer write it two women
wrote it no it was only one
and it was lena dunham
and she also directed it what
written
and directed
come on out you rapist
[Laughter]
no wonder it had the kid looking stuff
up on the internet yeah
you want to know if he's really yours
you look him in the eye
and you say
do you find me beautiful
not not like conventionally
that would be good
if any woman if my wife were to ask me
that that would be my answer because i
will never just say like don't ask me
overall or like out of everybody in the
room right now
i need context yeah like for this office
you're pretty cute
[Laughter]
but for this city
yeah i mean come on this is florida yeah
[Music]
and there's lena dunham she did she made
an appearance there she is with her new
haircut yeah that's why there she is you
thought it was a little
dad and husband that just can't happen
[Music]
it's gutsy
okay so it's not good
it's gutsy okay
none of these neither of you have any
do you have any of you have any [ __ ]
idea what this movie is about
no but i can tell you that all of these
words that they used in these reviews
don't tell me if it's good guys i have a
question
why does
one of the taglines say brutally honest
and it was attributed to roger ebert who
died april 4th 2013 of cancer
wait a minute right yeah you're seeing
that right you're seeing brutally honest
and then roger ebert am i wrong does he
have a kid maybe named rodriguez
you know what i'm telling you it's it's
because
these are probably reviewed like this is
probably things they've said about lena
dunham
because she's very gutsy
so it would describe her just as much as
the film
fupa e
[Laughter]
roger ever loved it
i kind of feel like this movie wasn't
made when roger ebert died
born died yeah i knew i was like i was
i think you're wonderful and that's it
[Music]
okay
why women always write men so gay in
ways that men aren't like it's so weird
the way women perceive men and how they
yeah
because you can't even say oh they're
writing men the way they want men to be
they're writing men the way they think
they want men to be right but when men
are really like this then you just cheat
on them and then like take the kids and
divorce them and ruin their lives right
and then you're like i don't know he was
just two nights
there you have it i got an answer for
you guys so rogerebert.com
they didn't put that though they didn't
put that though did they they put roger
eve all these
by the way not like rodriguez was a good
reviewer anyway he sucked a lot of
people suck his dick because he was one
of the few that was on tv but honestly
if you look back at some of his reviews
he rated some amazing movies poorly
because he's just a [ __ ] old fart you
know i liked gene siskel more
yeah you know what i like gene cisco
more too because at the end they hated
each other
oh yeah famously yeah yeah yeah they
famously hated each other
which i don't understand why you guys
review movies for goddamn living like
how can there be so much beef
i i yeah it is odd right like it was an
easy gig yeah
so you sit down and you both go thumbs
up or thumbs down and
and that's the other thing i don't know
why they hated each other they agreed
like the majority of the time on movies
as well like very rarely were they split
some so you know what we're on rumble so
a lot of you boomers know what we're
talking about
i was having an affair with a married
man and i know that makes me sound like
i have no morals or scruples
wait a second so
she's just cheated
yeah that's
that's what they do
i give my soul and body to this man and
then just in an instant so sorry baby
i'm so sorry oh
please baby
mr joe could you please
go wait
his wife
is lena dunham
and he cheated
on his wife
lena dunham
with
her is that correct
i suppose
oh this is [ __ ] terrible why this is
terrible why is this a thing bro
please
i'm trying to understand how this could
have happened to me
am i bad at sex
i don't know how to tell you you don't
have to are
is that the joke they're doing
that the girl thinks a [ __ ] is
literally blowing
this is bad and women are funny why
they're not oh they're not
oh you [ __ ]
oh you [ __ ] think you're funny
oh
oh good good good i just i saw the ratio
good good
good there's hope for humanity still
i do love the fact that people are still
down voting things and most of them
can't even see it
that makes the down votes count even
more in my opinion yeah exactly
because you're not gonna stop below
i must execute a plan
nobody
will ever
have the chance to do this to me
are you gonna again him
i have to be brave
you're a joke
how do you get over them so quickly
there's literally a million of them
not everyone is perfect
so this movie
sucks
selena dunham
only knows how to
yes but she's only sorry she only knows
how to write
amy schumer level comedy where it's all
about girls [ __ ] and getting [ __ ]
okay
least of all me
[Music]
you know they name they they name this
movie after what they have to poke lena
dunham with every morning make sure
she's alive
[Laughter]
also what she has to use to scratch her
back yeah
i like her ass
well that's the first one thanks frozen
you pieces frozen
all right what's the name why do we do
this on fridays man i don't know because
we hate ourselves in the self-inflicted
pain stages no i like myself i hate
frozen barely
wow what a narcissist versus me yes
how to spot a narcissist